allez à la bâtiaz justement les chérir
gardé de tweets publiés jamal sur les
réseaux sociaux tout le monde en a parlé
de ça un défi voile a indiqué ajouté il
consiste à ajouter une tranche de
fromage en pleine phase de votre bébé en
filmant sa réaction c'est un défi
complètement débile absurde et
irresponsable
c'est le challenge alors regardez le
tiche challen dites moi si vous êtes
choqués ou pas on va vous à expliquer
tout ça c'est le buzz du moment c'est
parti internet est le fournisseur numéro
un de défis et de challenge en tout
genre et ce n'est pas cette nouvelle
mode qui vient de faire son apparition
sur les réseaux qui fera mentir cette
tradition en effet la grande mode du
moment s'appelle le challenge en france
est le défi du fromage un titre qui
porte bien son nom p le concept jeté une
tranche de fromage au visage de son bébé
et filmer sa réaction
[Musique]
un buzz tels que les adultes s'y mettent
aussi et même les chiens si les vidéos
collecte des millions de vu la réaction
de certains internautes et des
professionnels de l'enfance ne sont pas
tout à fait en phase avec ce challenge
certains considèrent même que cette
pratique s'apparente à de la
maltraitance
bref encore un défi mystérieux dont il
est difficile de connaître l'origine
[Musique]
alors est ce que est ce que ça nous
sommes pas banal parce que savard est ce
que ça ça sent donc chez vous arrête tu
m'as mais d'être hyper fière quand vous
ça sent pas bon fromage et arrête en
fait c'est que chez libé dont v10 qui
vous avait caché c'est pas moi alors
quoi en fait si on le fait à des adultes
bon allez pourquoi pas c'est débile
mince alors quand vous êtes j'imagine ça
vous amuse que ça vous plaît oui ça me
voilà ça mais deux blessés de le faire
sur jean milési fait boire bas vous avez
regardé tout plein nez
[Rires]
j'ai envie de le faire mais bon on a
envie de vous écraser sur la tronche sur
la tranche à qui venait l'heure - outre
le fait face à drogba les véhicules en
plus fagace plus de nourriture pour le
manger après par ailleurs effectivement
il ya beaucoup de pédopsy qui disent que
le faire aller notamment les enfants en
bas âge c'est les assimiler à une
agression parce que l'enfant ne comprend
pas un foie celui qui est censé être
maternant sauvé qui tendent à être
réconfortant et lui apporter du
bien-être lui jette quelque chose au
visage et ensuite rit donc car il ya une
vraie 10h à 12h à moi ça me choque j'ai
vu la première vidéo j'ai été choqué
alors ah ouais je suis tout petit et je
suis une enfant battu donc ça me choque
doublement honnêtement qu'on voit un
bébé
et lorsqu'on voit le bébé se retourner
on a l'impression qu'il va se prendre
une gifle et c'est presque pas loin du
mois 6 mois ci sur un adulte à la voile
avec jeunes adultes
oui comme un enfant franchement moi ça
me va c'est très grave non voiture un
bébé moi je suis alors souvent les cg
non malgré les mêmes et donc j'ai
pédopsy qui disent que disent également
que non mais que notamment parfois on
dit oui me regarde et il y en a qui
sourit à des bébés qui sourient et ils
disent que ça même plus grave parce que
ça veut dire que l'enfant est habitué à
ce type de violence ou torse est long
bien sûr la bouche parce que ça peut
provoquer quasiment à chaque un sac
rester à toi de l'enfant
l'affaiblissement je suis allé beaucoup
trop mais c'est vrai ça chez moi un choc
quoi déjà il s'en souvient pas l'enfant
l'enfant mais de l'enfant de plus tard
il va vivre sa vie c'est arrivé à la
vache qui rit elles sont déjà gardien
c'est une vache ses usages ses ouvrages
et le que dit jean michel est d'une
absurdité de total et grâce à cet âge là
que le ferry ge la mémoire exe landes on
va intégrer dans sa mémoire qu'on peut
le battre il va essayer d'intégrer ces
enfants s'amuser il faut voir comment
ces faits par les parents si on leur
fait
on leur envoie le truc pour rigoler on
est avec nous c'est comme quand on prend
les enfants par les pieds et qu'on les
fait berner comme ça on a une très belle
imitation d'enfants on va y aller
franchement on va passer avec la
propagande escalade
après pape envoient une tomme de bruyère
au quai d'escale un curseur jockey comme
moi
les enfants sont les adultes d'ailleurs
je ferai une soirée si j'allais vous
inviterai et on va te le père oui wade a
été choqué quaden doc adulte il a été
choqué de bruit je sache c'est vrai